[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
presented
by fanduel but it's live in the bleacher
report app i almost fumbled through
aaron but i picked it back up i'm greg
ivory alongside
aaron dolan
i gotta know your take here and i gotta
know your take did lebron throw the
elbow on purpose
and are the lakers in trouble
well the lakers are in trouble
regardless of the lebron situation but
in terms of the of the lebron situation
since everyone is talking about it you
and i kind of debated at the beginning
of the show or i should say excuse me
before the show was it a closed fist or
was it an elbow every angle looks a
little different some angles look like
it's an accident some angles look like
it's totally intentional so nobody knows
the real answer but lebron james and
unfortunately he couldn't make it for
today's show so
unfortunately lebron couldn't make it we
don't we do we do want to know you guys
comment was it an elbow or a closed fist
you guys let us know in the comments
aaron i have another question
thanksgiving is coming up thanksgiving
is coming up better side
on thanksgiving mac and cheese
or stuffing
i'm gonna say neither
i think that we should normalize normal
food for thanksgiving because there's a
reason why we only eat these foods on
thanksgiving is because you only want it
once a year it is not tasty it is really
not that delicious turkey is the last
meat i would choose to eat i told my my
mom who's making dinner to make some
sweet potatoes or something that's a
little bit different but for me i don't
eat either of those things how about you
uh erin i i'm taking the mac and cheese
for sure
stuffing i don't know what that is but i
know what dressing is my mom makes a
mean dressing so i'm taking both of
those and i'm thankful for both of those
uh wait you need to know what else
somebody's stressing
what's dressing
people in the audience people that know
what dressing is you guys let us know
what dressing is in the comments let
aaron know what dress it's similar to
stuffing it's just
cooked or it's it's a little different
just a little different i don't know any
whipping is either so i don't i it's
neither here nor there
[Laughter]
aaron we gotta we we probably gotta
invite you to an ivory thanksgiving
feast to get you all this flavorful
flavorful food uh but as always we're
giving away locks we're giving away
hoodies and we're giving away jersey so
get in the comments make sure you guys
get in the comments
and i need gifts i need emojis but most
importantly i need winners only please
aaron are you ready to get in hop into
it
are you ready to hop into it you know
what today is right you know what today
is right
today is tnt tuesdays that means fanduel
is boosting the three by two in both
games making it
three by tuesday the question is will
there be two three pointers in the first
three minutes of
tonight's game last week the three by
two crash uh a cash with the golden
state warriors taking on the next let's
actually take a look at the highlights
let's take a look at the highlight and i
will
walk you guys through it uh the first
one was patty mills and then you guys
know who this is steph curry
that's 30. that's 30. he does what he
does
yes definitely one of my favorite people
uh 30 does what he does in the 3x2 cash
but today we asked you on twitter which
three by two will cash tonight we have
the lakers taking on the knicks and we
have the nuggets taking on the blazers
and uh here is the results
i'm kind of surprised wow aaron
tell us why i'm a little surprised
you're a little i mean yeah they both
have to shoot her in the first boat
denver and portland have been denver
portland they have shooters dane you
know cj yeah michael porter like they
have they have guys that are
more than capable of making uh two
three-pointers in the first three
minutes so get in the comments and you
guys let me know which 3x2 is a lock
aaron which one do you like better
well just a reminder you can bet on both
of them but i'm going with the lakers
knicks i think that the knicks can
actually score both of the three
pointers in or excuse me two of the
three pointers in the first three
minutes you have kevin walker evan
fournier julius randle they're gonna be
at home at the garden i'm taking that
first game for the three by two to cash
heron is rocking with the first game let
me hop into the comments let me hop into
the comments and see what you guys are
rocking with in the comments i got uh
i got
ak-47 big blue says both he's rocking
with both of them
i got gaff inc 2 says nugget blazers
shout out to you
gap inc 2. uh
dame is hitting both go garden says dame
is hitting both shots shout out to you
westbrook 34 says westbrook is going to
make one of those threes no lie and the
knicks may just get the rest shout out
to everybody i mentioned you guys are
walking away with a hoodie aaron i'm
gonna ride with the people here the 3x2
that we are riding unfortunately is not
the los angeles lakers versus the knicks
but i love your play aaron and i hope
that you win but we are riding the
denver nuggets versus the portland trail
blazers
let's go dame hit both of them why not
but we are riding that 3x2 let's move on
let's talk about my guy russell
westbrook we asked you in the app how
many points will russell score tonight
get in the comments and let us know
tell us what you think at the end of the
game we'll dm one random person who gets
closest and hook you up with a jersey
aaron the line is currently at 19 and a
half
lebron is out
what do you think
so westbrook had 26 points last game
scoring 15 of 26 in that fourth quarter
to rally against the pistons of course
lebron james was taken out of that game
so some may be thinking kind of like you
are that lebron is out maybe russell
westbrook is going to go off but when
james was out for eight games due to
that abdominal strain russell westbrook
only averaged 21 points he's averaging
19 on the season but i'm still going to
go with the under here which is not a
popular play just given that the knicks
defense is allowing 42 points in the
paint which is better than the majority
of the teams in the league so i'm
rocking with the under for his point
sprout
aaron i love the play love the play but
i'm going the other way simply because
we're just gonna we're just gonna do
simple scent we're just gonna add it up
simply like this
russell westbrook is going to new york
russell westbrook is playing at madison
square garden therefore russell
westbrook will try to put on the show no
lebron james he's going to be trying to
rock some babies he's going to be trying
to rock some rims he's going to be
throwing passes we know that that's what
he's going to do but we
we know russ is just going to try to
show up at madison square garden so i i
got to rock with the over here here i
have to rock with the over but it's not
about what i think
it's not about what i think it's about
what the people think and i'm in the
comments right now this is the handy
dandy what's up everybody that do not
know
i'm seeing a lot i got d johnson saying
yeah i am seeing a lot of 29's d
johnson396 says 23. so he's rocking with
the over shout out to you d johnson uh
not ronald acuna jr says he'll score 27.
shout out to you
uh g quinn 26 says wow under i'm shocked
he's shocked by your under it is okay it
it is okay uh remember after the game
we're gonna hit up one person
yeah i mean aaron you you you you know
you got love in the comments they love
you one soldier in there we don't have
to we don't have yeah we don't have to
question we don't have to question
whether they love you in the comments we
know that they love you in the comments
aaron but i want the people to remember
after the game we're going to hit up one
person and hook you up with a jersey
aaron let's move on to your favorite
part of the show let's talk major
markets money lines against the spread
and point totals for tonight's game
let's take a look at the odds aaron what
are you seeing here and what do you like
so i'm gonna go over 215 in the nuggets
versus portland game the over 7-1 in the
last eight meetings speaking of the last
meeting between these two teams which
was on november 14th over 215 did hit if
that was the um total set for the game
the uh denver nuggets actually won that
game 124 to 95 but damien learned did
not play in that game with an abdominal
injury this time nicole yokin is still
waiting to see on his status for this
game he is currently questionable he was
out the last two games of that wrist
injury but i'm still gonna go with the
over for this game because we kind of
talked about this already a little bit
damien lillard he's he's out of that
shooting slump so i think these teams
can go off
i love that erin i love that i'm
actually gonna ride with you on that
over uh i i looked up a stat in portland
in their last three games went over this
total in their last three games so i
think that trend is gonna continue i
think that i think they're gonna be hot
you mentioned dame uh you know the
offensive firepower that they have in
portland but not only do they have
offensive firepower in portland so does
denver so i'm riding with you with the
over i'm in the comments and i want to
see what they're riding with i'm in the
comments giving away hoodies uh
yeah they they're they're saying it's
all love g twin 26 and it's all love
here aaron it is all love i have uh i
have young gravy 56 says trailblazers
dame will drop 60 tonight shout out to
you and you're both big numbers
superman tonight in the comments
superbad says
nasir little gets 15 points off the
bench he said let's go blazers so i
think he's taking the blazers money line
then he's sprinkling in a bet for us
saying nicer little 15 points off the
bench shout out to everybody that i just
mentioned you are walking away with
hoodies aaron
let's move on we talked major markets
now let's talk player props we're gonna
play a little game called lock or
not i'm gonna put up a prop i'm gonna
put up a prop and you guys get in the
comments and tell me whether it's a lock
or it's not aaron are you ready
yes let's do it
let's get right to it let's get right to
it first up is dame
to score over 24 and a half points in
tonight's denver portland uh match-up
the odds are at
the odds are at -106 aaron for the over
is that a lock or is it not
that is a lock dame has found his stride
26 points he's averaging the last seven
consecutive games he's actually
increasing as well uh his shooting
shooting percentage which is up to 39
which is still relatively sub-par
compared to his previous seasons but i
think he's out of the you know the
shooting slump we're seeing things
trending upward for him so i'm
definitely going to take the over for
this game
i love that i love that take aaron this
is surprising i know dave's been
struggling but
and a half points really damian lillard
go get that dame i'm rocking right there
with you i'm we're sending those good
vibes aaron's sending them from
philadelphia i'm sending them from the
bay aaron uh dame go get
that go hit that over we're riding with
you uh let's move on next up is paul
george
actually before i move on before i move
on let me hop into the comments because
the people are here for hoodies i'm in
the comments and i got bad sports take
says lock all day dame is about to go
off shout out to you uh rich bartel is
also in the comments saying that's a
lock baby shout out to both of you guys
both of you guys are walking away with
hoodies next up is paul george sitting
at 25 points airing
is the over a lock or not
so these two teams actually just met
with the clippers winning by six points
paul george posted 29 points in that win
26 on the season so the over is a lock
for this one as well
aaron is rocking with the over
i i'm gonna have to follow you aaron i'm
gonna have to follow you mentioned he uh
he just scored 29 he averages 26 is
sitting that 25 and a half paul pg
facing the ma go get 26 bro go get 26.
you you should be a you're walking
bucket pg is definitely uh under the
definition of a walking bucket so just
go get 26.
yeah he has he has been really good this
season uh no kawhi so he's the guy in
los angeles uh let's move on aaron let's
move on actually
before we move on i gotta talk to the
people i gotta talk to the people i
gotta i gotta figure i just need some
vibe from the people i need some vibes
uh and good vibes i got
em go blue emgo blue says no he says no
that paul george is not going to go over
i wonder why it would not ronald cunha
is back
he's back he's back he's giving his
takes in two locks in a row he's he's
gave us two locks in a row two weeks in
a row shout out to you uh
i also have maxwell rexella saying over
so shout out to everybody that i
mentioned you guys are walking away with
hoodies
let's go to reggie jackson let's pull
that back up control room he's sitting
at 17 and a half
17
points
a half points is the over a lot or not
on this one
um in terms of his points i feel like
you have to go with a lot towards the
over at this point i just took three
overs so i just think it's going to be a
great night all around for all of these
teams but definitely going to take the
over for him as well
aaron is taking the overall my guy
reggie jackson and and i i rode with
aaron on the first two i'm why switch it
up why switch up the vibes
reggie jackson go get 18 points brother
taking on the mavs i think he can do it
he was a bucket in the playoffs last
year that's transferring into this
season yeah reggie jackson he's a bucket
down there in l.a
but let's move on to this last segment
because we all know you guys love the
the same game parlay so br betting is
now building our own
same game parlay and giving you guys an
opportunity to ride with us and tonight
on the inside the nba pre-game show
chuck my boy charles barkley is gonna
look at our parlay and pick his favorite
leg
before i tell you what it is i need you
guys to get in the comments get in the
comments and tell me what you guys think
of the parlay grade the parlay tell me
which legs is gonna hit tell me which
legs is not gonna hit just dissect the
parlay in the comments we need vibes
though we definitely need vibes this
week we're looking at the lakers taking
on the knicks no lebron let's get right
to it let's get right to it we're going
to start it off with my guy russ
we're going to start it off with my guy
russ aaron
russell westbrook to score
20 points now i know you went under
aaron do you like this leg of the parlay
or not
well i can't say i like the first leg of
the parlay which just completely ruins
the rest of the parlay because i like
the under 19 and a half but apparently
you're going against me
so
let's see the other legs hopefully i
have positive vibes for the other ones
uh hopefully we get better vibes for the
next aaron we're going to stay with russ
we're going to stay with russ
we know he likes to dish the ball we
know he likes to ditch the ball so aaron
eight plus assists come on now i need
good vibes here rush to get eight
assists i'm yeah okay thank you thank
you thank you we're getting good vibes
she said that that's easy okay we're
locked in with that one let's move on
let's move on to the next one
julius randle
julius randle the other 30
the other 30 in new york uh sitting at
eight
plus rebounds aaron do you think he can
grab eight for us tonight
i do he's averaging ten rebounds on the
season and so far this is my favorite
leg so we're getting more positive as it
goes down
yes
the positivity i love the positive vibes
i love the positive let's move on to
this last leg aaron we got rj
buried let me take a deep breath one
more time
rj barrett sitting at 15 plus points
aaron
i took a deep breath i had to take a
deep one there do you like why do you
need a deep breath for this one are you
is this your least favorite rj barrett
it's rj bearhead i mean he's averaging
15 points per game this season so it
can't be that bad of a bet
yeah yeah i mean okay okay aaron is
sending the good vibe she's making us
feel good i appreciate that uh
well let's pull up the ticket so we can
show the people at home yeah
what if they was to put some money on
this parlay what it would turn into
there it is you guys see it yeah you
guys see it you put 100 down you walk
away with 400
400 and some change and we gonna call
that 400 and some change
481 dollars
that's not something
that's some change that's a dinner
that's a drink in vegas that's that's
some change that is a drinking bacon uh
maybe two up here it's a drinking
veggies
hey you guys can get on fanduel and ride
with us aaron before i get into the
comments before i get into the comments
i need you to put on your teacher's hat
a little bit right here and grade our
same game parlay what grade do you give
our same game parlor
i have to give you a c minus because we
started off the show with you asking me
russell westbrook's point prop 19 and a
half i said under and then you take 20
plus as the first leg so i can't give
you a good grade just considering you
completely went against your co-host so
we're gonna have to rock with the c
a c
minus aaron you know what i like to i
like to take the positive out of things
and uh in college c's actually led me to
my degree so therefore c's get degrees
so i'm going to take it i'm going to
take the c minus i'm going to take it
with love
yeah
i'm taking it and running with it and
actually you know what i'm running to
the comments right now because it's time
to give away a jersey and it's time to
wait to give away some hoodies uh i
wanna know like okay enderman enderman's
he's giving us a shout out to you uh
enderman for rocking with us um
i'm in the comments i am in the comments
looking for a good take i see
r-c-a-t-a-l-a-n-o
that is for
the producers he says take
bear it off the parlay he says take
barrett off to parley aaron guess what
i'm gonna do for this for this lucky
commenter i'm gonna
give them a jersey
simply because they sent bad vibes our
way but guess what we don't return we
don't return
bad vibes with bad lives we turn those
bad vibes into good vibes so rc
is a walking
i'm a walking sunset hey i have a
but hey yeah the guy that i just
mentioned rc yeah a-t-l-a-n-o the
producers know you're walking away with
a jersey air let me hop in here and give
away some hoodies
let me hop marked one says they're with
you aaron they're rocking with you i
don't know what they're with you with
but they're with you so just because
they're with you i'm giving them a
hoodie uh
mcfly
mcfly mcfly says randall double double
and the win should love the take i'm
giving you a hoodie as well aaron let's
move oh actually
i want you to get in the comments aaron
get in the comments and uh
write some love i've been spreading a
lot of love i want you to like some of
them i think
somebody keeps putting in dwight schrute
over and over and over again um
oh my gosh i just try to find
m-f-l-y-d-e reggie 20 and a win a lock
thank you for being part of the combo
okay
appreciate you thank you and you get
everybody convo
you get a hoodie you caught aaron's
people are in here spamming you
oh yeah they're spamming big time in the
comments it's all love though it is all
love aaron are you ready for this next
one before we hop into it i'm going to
let you guys know i told you guys
earlier in the year and i'm telling you
again to bet the warriors to win the
finals aaron the winners are 15-2 clay
is coming back and the nets are 13-5 yet
the nets are still
favorite to win it all i need you guys
at home to get in the comments and tell
me who you think should be a favorite
to win it all
let's take a look at the latest odds and
let's take a look at the latest odds the
warriors are currently second favorite
at plus 650
another deep breath right there aaron
should the warriors should they be the
overall favorite should they be the
overall favorite
at this point i think they should i mean
we're almost one-fourth into the season
i think the warriors after what we have
seen should be favored against just the
first five weeks and they have had a
relatively easy schedule compared to
some of the other teams in the league
meanwhile a team like the heat they're
actually the top three of the hardest
schedules so make sure to keep an eye on
them again just through week five the
lakers keep moving back not surprising
and as for the nets they stay pretty
consistent in terms of their odds
despite the absence of kyrie irving and
i get that they're 13 and five so
oddsmakers thinking they should be able
to you know be the favor and they were
the pre-season favorite as well but in
those five losses for the nets they've
lost to milwaukee charlotte miami
chicago and golden state i mean come on
if they play a hard team they lose so i
do not think the brooklyn nets should be
the favorite anymore i don't see them
being able to win everything with kyrie
irving
on the bench as for the warriors i think
they're a team that's been very
surprising so far this season and will
probably continue to shock us plus
they're going to get some players back
so i do think the warriors should be
favored or even less money at this point
when you mentioned the warriors when you
mentioned the warriors in like your last
sentence it just made me smile because
we're good you said it all we're good
this year i've been
i've been telling i've been telling
y'all before the season everybody was
like oh the warriors the warriors they
barely made the hc we got some key
additions we got some iguodala balitza
uh uh otto porter uh gary payton the
second
come on we got some good additions to
this team the warriors are they're
looking good they're sitting at plus 650
you guys should go ahead go bet it now
i'm giving you guys what to do go bet
the warriors and players are coming back
for that
they're gonna get better towards the
second half of the season aaron
i just forgot the most important part i
can't believe that i just forgot me greg
ivory warriors fan forgot the most
important part we're getting a number
one overall draft pick and klay thompson
back to just add to this 15 and two team
already yeah the rich is getting richer
in in san francisco the rich is getting
richer and golden state the warriors
should win the finals so you guys put
that bet in
aaron i think it's time to talk to the
people let's talk to the people let's
let's get their takes let's see they're
riding with us
uh
i got enderman he says yes sir we're
warriors he has gary payton shout out to
you
uh i got g quinn warrior should be
number one shout out to you thank you g
quinn rich bartels is back in the
comments saying warriors all day
righteous 144 righteous 144 says pacers
righteous 144 you were walking away with
a hoodie
everybody else i said thank you guys for
commenting it's still love i think you
guys probably already got hoodies but
righteous 4144 you were walking away
with a hoodie aaron i think it's time to
take this thing on home i think it's
time to take this thing go home
thank you guys for tapping into the
group chat presented by fanduel remember
what you learned today the 3x2 is a lot
every week just take it just and believe
in the sunset
russ
over is cashing he's in madison square
garden he's in new york he's going to be
rocking the baby so the over is crashing
get on fanduel and tell the br betting
same game parlay and tune into the
inside the nba pre-game show inside the
nba pre-game show with chuck
shack kenny chuck is going to be uh he's
going to be talking about his favorite
leg of our parlay so uh make sure you
guys tune into that we'll be back next
week giving out hoodies giving out
jerseys giving out locks if you won one
today we will dm you not me not aaron
but be our betting will do you and i'm
sad to say
sad to say that aaron dolan will be
leaving the group chat unfortunately
she's leaving the group chat this is her
last show with us so let's get in the
comments and drop some sunsets for her
aaron we wish you the best thank you for
being a part of the squad thank you and
group chat was fun aaron why don't you
it definitely was fun we had fun here
when we had much fun in the group chat
and as to send you off and to
to to just just get in the comments get
in the comments and give them in the
comments
go ahead yeah go ahead scan your
comments
take it all the way home and to the bank
hopefully we didn't give him a hoodie
yet
love that and let's give him another man
we definitely gave him why not
oh my gosh there's so many sentences
give him a hoodie too everybody's
getting hoodie everybody she mentioned
is getting a hoodie
yeah there you go
keep on going aaron
e-e-b-z
that's as much as i can get they're
coming through quick i appreciate the
sunset greg ivory will definitely be
keeping the positive vibes here on the
group chat
yes yes yes aaron
thank you for joining the group chat i
mean uh thank you guys
for riding with us
get on fanduel ride with us follow us on
social alongside aaron dolan i'm greg
ivey wishing you and your families all a
great thanksgiving
me and aaron we're leaving the group
chat
peace see ya
[Music]
you